ils ont été plusieurs centaines à
répondre à l'appel du collectif prônons
la vie pour défendre le droit au
logement et protester contre les
expulsions et les logements chers en
appelle à la mobilisation qui a été
lancé dans tout le pays
cette mobilisation ici à paris elle a
débuté place du châtelet aux alentours
de 15 heures parmi sept parmi ce cortège
plusieurs associations de plusieurs
syndicats également venu soutenir cette
cause du logement je vous propose
d'écouter les témoignages de personnes
qui veulent nous avons pu parler d'eux
d'entre elles subissent la précarité au
logement écouter le message il faut
traiter les femmes et son papier comme
des êtres humains parce que les sans
papiers ce sens ce sont des êtres
humains surtout les enfants là bas pour
les enfants alors pour cette période de
crise il faut penser rousse offert aux
familles sans papiers quand vous pensez
à autre fin du mois moi ça fait quatre
ans que je suis là je dis que je suis un
être humain quand vous on vient tous de
la même planète et
franchement on vivre on peut enlever on
veut vivre dignement nous sommes là
aujourd'hui nous soutenons le droit au
logement parce que c'est un droit
fondamental et aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est d'abord la spéculation financière
qui fait que ce droit au logement qui
est un droit fondamental n'est pas
respectée et que aujourd'hui on est en
france dans un pays où il ya 10 millions
de personnes pauvres et parmi ces 10
millions de personnes peau beaucoup sont
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
en terme d'hébergement d'habitation et
notre réaction radicale elle est sur le
terrain et dans les institutions
réclamer un changement des droits sur le
terrain c'est de dire attention il ya
beaucoup plus de gens expulsables satané
que jamais avant parce qu'on n'a jamais
vu une telle différence entre les prix
de vente
les loyers et l'impossibilité de payer
les loyers pendant la période qu'ovide
est donc actuellement il ya pratiquement
toutes les expulsions de l'année
dernière + 7 de cette année le tout vu
du volume de menaces d'expulsions que
d'habitude
un rassemblement qui était censée se
terminer devant le ministère de
l'écologie puisque l'écologie est un des
thèmes abordés par tous les collectifs
ici présent le droit au logement aux
normes écologiques 1 mais les forces de
l'ordre en ont décidé autrement
et finalement la dispersion a été faite
boulevard saint germain